we're all wired to serve naturally as
children as kids as people as humans but
we've been educated for greed and you
see this there's countless viral videos
of kids who like walk up to their
television screen and wipe the cartoon
characters uh tears off with their
tissues or like kids like running to
help the person next to them and we were
all once that person
but it's just the education that we get
and I'm not just too much school I'm
just saying generally the the education
of becoming self-centered and whether
you look at from a scientific point of
view the studies that have been done
when people help people their depression
goes down their mental health goes up
when people help people they're able to
feel more joy and experience more
happiness in their lives like we are
happier when we serve and help people